foreign
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right I know you don't
we also need courage
[Music]
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made the plants so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not Roman
why do you come to us
I just want to keep my family safe
[Music]
treat them as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
far sport
if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe
breathe
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Outcast that's all they see
[Music]
I see
[Music]
my warrior like you I'm supposed to
fight
protect the people
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get it done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]
tickets on sale now
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
boy meet up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there I'm coming
with you
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
who knows how to hunt
I know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever did this I can kill it
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hold up
[Music]
be all right here
just reach pumpkin
I was scared
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
isn't it
it's really nice
you can hold it
what is it
it's a puzzle
[Applause]
and it's almost finished
keep going
so if I solve it
do I get a prize
I do
[Music]
watching it has six sides six
configurations
it opens up
[Applause]
collect
it's time
greater Delights await we wish to see
you proceed
their blood
their pain
all for us
I want to see you pray for
I thought I had something
that thing is stalking us
[Music]
we head for that Island it'll come for
us again but it's not gonna stop
tell it
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl you look just like your mother
[Music]
I am gonna get her back
genetic power has not been Unleashed
a terrible mistake
the Doomsday Clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive it matters
is what we do now I can use your
expertise you coming or what
a baby Raptor I made a promise we would
bring her home you made a promise to a
dinosaur yeah why
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
that biggest carnivore the world has
ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
no one knows how it starts
but when the fear begins
when the paranoia takes over
foreign it makes people do terrible
things
good morning
as you can see some of you have chosen
to stay home today given what's been
happening
[Music]
Carrie internet character that tells you
to kill people it made this kid stab his
own mother there's a lot of people
freaking out about it nobody knows what
it actually is
foreign
[Music]
calls about it all night
how are we supposed to protect our
family
my parents can't see it but when I try
to tell them what I saw just makes it
more hysterical
thank you
hey Dad can we start over
we can just sit down and I'll talk it
out together
I'm just trying to protect him
I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman it's so cool and I'm
just me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me super powers
well then everybody got super powers
where's everyone going
to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right come on
the faith of the world depends on it
[Music]
the children
very small Billy
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
we fight powers like this
you think I know how to fix this dude
but I really don't really everyone can
be worthy
fight for your family go fight for the
world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did Mom shoot someone's face this little
bump right here that's you I still miss
her every day
what's that there's something Crossing
up ahead
stay in the car okay just stay in the
car yeah okay
I've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks without eating a spray
Lions don't do that at least no lion
I've ever seen
go back to the cause
yeah
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's only law that matters
you shouldn't be out yet
don't move okay
[Music]
you won't believe what I found what is
see
yeah we are so alike you and I whisper
because we won't let this world crush us
but don't think that you can change the
Order of Things
Charles
yourself
The Citadel likes control
could open its doors to everyone there
wouldn't be enough resources
it's nothing
stop again
I'm Camellia
she's not our responsibility she's from
sister she's taking us there let's go
pilgrims Drifters Bandits
you have to be really careful who you
trust
the Citadel will be ruthless
that can't stop me
[Music]
you can change everything
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and the Earth was cyclists and empty and
the Darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
you ready Freddy
say hello there young lady good
afternoon
what is this place it's your new home
isn't it wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
I miss you I miss my son well you better
get used to it because you'll never see
either one of us ever again
mother how could you give Scott my
number he just wants to
why don't I come in
I don't need any help everything is
perfect
[Music]
okay
mom there's there's a monster outside my
window
you and I are completely safe like two
bugs snug in a rug
I want to go home
hi doctor I'm wondering if um maybe I
should go back on medication
Church
I think I have adenas in my house
[Applause]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
[Music]
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
I'm Sophie I'm Tim for a young man
passing it about music there's no
greater place to be than mozarts
and what's your instrument
to go show me what you got
enough what what's this
there's a real magic in this Wars
[Music]
what are you doing back there I have no
idea where I am the young friends bring
back my beloved daughter
should take a risk if you're going to
figure out what it is
[Music]
so you believe me that o'clock in the
school library is a portal into Mozart's
beloved Masterpiece yes no
Tom I know you're trying your best
would have been proud of you but I don't
think you'd feel the same way about
Lucas right now
you ready
this is gonna hurt
[Music]
what what was that
[Music]
we were just playing slap face
thank you
[Music]
what happened
did you see it
walked down on bowling lane come back
here Pig not far from where you guys are
at
Focus sometimes we do terrible things
we can't help ourselves
it's like good witchcraft I'd rather
wonder what he does with himself or
where he goes
you don't get it it's something juice
for us personally I gotta know are you
good
or evil
she doesn't eat out the bad kids
she's their friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Halloween you can't escape the
shock the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Airship is that I've never seen anything
like it baby clay what is the president
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition
I'm not my father
blur
no you were just a kid when you went
missing but now you're all we got
Mr Clay I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ]
your dad do you
do you forge his autograph
where in the world are we
Ethan you brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
foreign
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what
is this place the cliffs are alive and
the waters dissolve the flesh off your
bones everything down here is trying to
kill us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
I was too
I'm loving this family reunion come on
we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
she's that coming
[Music]
thank you